yes good yeah we're good yeah we're good
yeah let's start Monday now Brennan
might be a little bit oh dude well you
don't care huh
cuz you Wayne draw big [ __ ] you can is
that wrong
that's so aggressive you came out hotter
than your your hair headache when you
want to be greater left eye chain drop
fat [ __ ] chain drop fat [ __ ] long hair
don't care is Rock [ __ ] Monday so we
know that it's chained drop Monday now
well it's rock pokémon Jana you old [ __ ]
I don't have a chain but I want one I
wore one on stage my buddy Kevin Mac
gave me a chain he goes where my chain
when I was in Brandon I go what because
wear this I put it on and I looked sexy
and I had it I've never performed with a
chain on and in myself
mine was it just a small chain with a
little like like a Saint Catharine thing
on it like a little way yeah and I was
like tasteful chain now now Kevin if you
know Kevin Mac you don't know I'm right
tall 65 handsome son of a [ __ ] come
rides a Harley sponsor I think by India
and whatever the [ __ ] but a stud that
looks good on him he's looser guy and
some guy certain guys when you're when
you look like him I put it on at your
age and at my age but I was like and in
my sick mind I was like this might weigh
me down a little on solid state I was
like this is not my neck well right but
I've changed right before a show I'm
like I don't feel that comfortable I'm
be super self-conscious about it yeah
I'll run run and change yes sometimes my
shirt will be too tight because I shrunk
it as usual yeah or it's too little too
short and when I lift my arms up you can
see much that's not a little midriff
yeah you short a short sure it's there
my man I want to bring back the baby
shirt I want to cut it right right boom
enjoy it tit long game where than the
unaffiliated only guys like you know why
just gay so nice yeah cuz gay okay just
cuz gay is gay ha ha
Roger Goodell said said oh you guys
can't wear those anymore cuz can't wear
so she went why you goes gay cuz gay any
went fair point
yeah but gay gay gay Zinn sports we know
so the gays in sports maybe there are a
lot of gay men and women I know I wonder
what they're gonna start coming out well
it's hard you know what if Jon Jones was
like I'm like game I wish he'd do
something about it
like yeah no doubt I think it'd be great
he knows gonna do [ __ ] no no well if
Canelo came I was like I'm a gay redhead
then that would be an issue in Mexico I
would imagine there's a little contrived
Cacho machoism yeah I gotta tell you I'm
blown away that he won the way he did I
thought canna I thought Koval I was
gonna beat him because he was so big and
strong and hit so hard well you're
stupid really
you're a stupid no hey I'm not you're
stupid you're stupid like his older he
is all the last few five big it's so
hard
hmm yeah he's older new coach jab it's
just a matter of time I was waiting I
was like this come you were on earth
come on hello everybody knew hmm
do you let me piss in your mouth I would
[ __ ] punch you in the face I would do
what you know what I'll be honest with
you you know I train now with heatin
Machado we would know that which means
every celebrity quick hold on trains
every celebrity and the one me it's
special because we do private stuff and
we do some special [ __ ] I'm accelerating
my learning curve I also have a lot of
mad experience and fifties okay I'm
gonna keep going you also also if I clam
up and take the shots right so pump up
up
I literally figured out how to fight a
bigger man pop up set up and then you
just like Canelo do you answer back SATs
at Canelo did yeah I like those hooks
I'm gonna start working on my hooks
I gotta start taking my hooks more
seriously should do it I know I'm gonna
hold you now I'm gonna dump in your
mouth no don't say don't say dump cuz I
don't know what that means what do you
mean by dump to see it could meet a
couple things don't raise your eyebrows
like that either what's up with you bro
I'm gonna hold you down your orange
Cassidy right now are you ours kasi
orange Cassidy oh you don't know orange
Cassidy's do you guys oh it's crystal
Leah's new hero oh bring up arms Cassidy
he's aged I'm gonna dump in your mouth
bro he's a he's a wrestler he's
professional wrestler let me dump bro
here you go there is what you do well
why don't you go ahead and bring him up
and show a highlight of him rustling why
Shea how he wrestles say hi wrestles
hazel swagged out
oh yeah what Chris post like that's my
favorite guy ever some [ __ ] yeah and I
like making fun of them I get it no here
right they're all out that one right
there down there with where this bi
there you go let's see yeah hey go watch
this that Jesus Christ Mardan
just what Chris posted now this is what
I like about this guy I think watch this
Oh lights out
orange Cassady great name no no hell
yeah
yeah yeah he looks like Chris D'Elia and
Neil's had a baby need his hand cynic he
Oh with the Jay Leno prompt action dude
dinner table Wow yeah that's why he does
fight with his hands in his hands bro
you can stop it when you're as good with
your feet that's why I call me when I
was training Taekwondo I was I could've
kept my hands in my pocket and kicked
you right in the [ __ ] hey you throw a
kick in my head
we were gentle commercial for on it
yesterday for Black Friday kung-fu
commercial I think it'd be pretty good
and Brennan bring my weight can't kick
and I you know you can't and then he
went and then he threw a kick at my head
and I went oh oh
and then he goes like this really
obnoxiously anything you can do I can do
better when you're really fighting
correct yeah anything
why don't I was fine yesterday though
yeah should be good that's a good time
they didn't feed us though pet peeve
feed me didn't we had some fruit had
some fruit and some corn general corn
thank you look or well don't I hear
these corn products where they make a
corn product that just sits out there
like a flake of some kind
hmm yeah this is fine yes and now for
another episode of bombs at Ninja
yeah yeah how about how about shooting
how about shooting in general how about
being on set general how about posing
for Brian yeah weird live I'll tell you
what bothers me as we did that shoot
barefoot cuz the kung fu thinks we're in
like weird martial art clothes and being
barefoot flares up my oh yeah big time
oh yeah I I have to walk around the
house and shoes not because I have to
have those insults so I these these are
the joint chatter boards those are
adorable
thanks dude sweet boots these are a bun
stone and I have my insults look like
you've got such lesbian boots well they
are they are I know a lesbian wears
these and I'd be sucking I do titties
doing those doesn't go much more extreme
where I do you sure it's this Fight Club
hey can I see something
this is taric's gym yep can I say some
what's up my heart don't give those
shirts can I say sorry on this channel
hey I'm gonna dump in your mouth can I
say something god man
well we're shooting yesterday with our
friend Aubrey Marcus the Restonic crew
at the twins shout to the twins LSU
Tigers shout a tiger teammates big the
twins the big Victor twins you would not
shut the [ __ ] up about going to special
ones house I'm talking dude I'm just
friends you what you would have thought
Bryan was a 21 year old you asked me
what I did capture on week I do know in
any time I'd like no slide post time I'd
say hey I called Sylvester bro sorry's a
friend of mine well mr. Xylon he's right
on slide posted a video look I maybe did
I hang out at his house with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Al Pacino and and
Dolph Lundgren yeah did I not some other
people yeah was I was Sly Stallone sure
now did his living room smell like
testosterone and protein parts and death
uh-huh they the I tell you so with the
one thing about him over anything else
what was the one thing that surprised me
he's [ __ ] hilarious
he's [ __ ] hilarious like he's got the
best sense of humor which I never knew I
didn't know that was nuts what else I
know but
tell stories and I was like I said that
Frank Grillo I go dude he's [ __ ]
hilarious because I know he's got a
great sense of humor he tells [ __ ]
hilarious stories so that was really
cool and you guys were over there to
watch the fights yes and do they do they
like you if the unboxing the news oh yes
Arnold was course it was in the other in
the in the other room the screening room
watching the UFC we were watching the
boxing but they had the wave for the
boxing who they'll have the UFC was done
but anyway so we were running back and
forth and then we you know but it was
just really interesting I will say this
is all says the funniest oh yeah wait
the video and then I don't want you says
this comet mine shows this this is me
and Frank rolling over Al Pacino now
please read Will Sasso scammy Oh break
on his core screen time in this
Instagram post then he doesn't [ __ ]
Callen come on yeah Callen James Gunn -
now I will say this about his house and
and a lot of you are young and you're
gonna be like Brian and this is not a
responsible familiar thing for me to say
but I want to say it out loud say it's
about his house money buys happiness I
said it out loud did Sylvester seem
happy yeah he did yeah he did beautiful
family he's got a gorgeous got three
gorgeous daughters there's holler at me
he's got a his wife is my age and
couldn't look better she looks like if
his wife walked into a [ __ ] bar
research in if his wife walked into a
[ __ ] bar that's her there oh that's
his daughter if his wife welcome to a
bar with 30 year-olds they see everybody
would be trying to pick her up she's
sick hot get his daughters yeah and his
daughters are great his daughters are
[ __ ] great they're just good girls I
that was the crazy thing as they grew up
like royalty and their normal their
normal human beings
it's I won't get off their nuts um but
Arnold was cool too
yeah howdy kept going come on do it well
he's him is that his daughter just look
up oh yeah I can tell between the
Dodgers in the muck we're all sitting
that meeting in Arnold comes and goes
look at these criminals this is where
all the riffraff think Arnold was down
in his movie bombed well I don't get
momu until then I didn't care well he
didn't know until the next day
so yeah there they go there are the
girls come on
the man's tongue all right by himself
he's done all right
bill birnes there bill burr was there
and so I walk in and sly is smoking a
cigar with bill understanding their talk
and I walk in hey bill goes hey what's
up and burn a fter an hour cuz like it's
Al Pacino you understand I grew up with
these guys they're part of my history
what would it's not it's not a little
thing for me it's Al Pacino it's so vest
on it's almost oars there it for me
there wasn't when you talk about why'd
you become an actor
you got to include you have to put out
Sylvester Stallone in Rocky yeah and and
you have to put Al Pacino in there as
some of the biggest influences of my
life and some of the reasons I got into
this [ __ ] business in the first place
so I'm looking at people that are part
of my history and and and there are
all-time greats so at one point Arnold
and I think sly a talking Al Pacino's
over there and I'm just kind of standing
there and I'm like looking at this my
history and I'm looking at and
Bilborough come over to sit down and
Bill burr goes hey you've been here over
an hour get over it already
all right let's get over it dude this is
I know tell me about it even he's the
same way you know Bill's pretty famous
now but it doesn't matter you're like
[ __ ] he's part of our there there's
so much of a part of our childhood then
you're you're at their house it's so but
guess what they are
just like us regular dudes funny silly
geese all about laughing he has all
three girls yeah a couple things you
don't know about sly a couple things we
should talk about with sly hell of a
painter hell of a painter which I was
blown away by he can really paint and
he's a professional horseman
professional we're up on horseback polo
pony and competed on a high level which
I didn't know so I'm just still making
the [ __ ] Rambo's in the last one I
was the I don't know when the new one
comes out but the one before that was
pretty good
violin it's fun oh yeah any good well he
stayed relevant since 1935 when him is
not relevant since 1975 dude when him
and Arnold did that escape the prison
movie good movie man hell yeah he's
something else it seems like he's got
really good friendships and I think it
comes from having a good family anyway
yeah it's been the business for so I
anyway guys if you need me on Saturdays
fight nights I'll probably over at my
friend's house cool cool is that Antonio
Banderas yeah man
time gets us all [ __ ] the time gets
us this Oh does the oven Instagram page
and and nobody's mounting a stronger
challenge to time than our our then uh
then our boy
Stallone but it gets us off don't give
him up the fight yeah
he's getting up old Marat oh yeah he's
got to be sixty something right how old
is he
he looks pretty good yeah that's his fan
there I don't think so
it's his daughter 59 hmm only seven
years old and you'd be okay well that'll
be mean that will be you me fun no dude
maybe fun when you look like that yeah
fun of me yeah every day how would you
do that why is it okay to make fun of
somebody who died slowly this one though
because you get to death the more
ruthless your friends are we're all
getting older than yeah I don't know I
don't I can toss a mouse on the way here
cuz it's a shout-out to Andrew Schultz
it's his birthday on Friday I think it's
Thursday and he's 37 I don't know if I'm
36 or 37 gun to the head hey dude 36 to
couldn't tell you I don't know wait what
do you I don't know how old I am
shut up I don't know come here
driver's license and I'll tell you March
18 1983 to the math I will not be able
to do it who's gonna neither of you get
a math get 37 cat there I'm seven I'll
be 38 March I'm not great in that crazy
I've known you since you were 29 I think
how long how long ago was that it was a
long time ago yeah Wow Wow time falafel
fly is 37
I guess whoo-hoo what I don't know how I
enjoy it well cuz you're a turning 38
you're damn near 40 now well I'm still
two years I'm just saying that's how old
are you chin 42
there you go that's why I feel that's
why you celebrate that cat what are you
24 Scott dog gets old cat dog God dog
for men it's easy after you know it's
still coming your own I believe it a
hundred percent believe what well for
men as you get older there's cynicism
well I thought it was interesting that
you know everybody from Stallone to
anybody no matter how successful you are
you go through periods of time when you
feel like it's over and you're
irrelevant so I told the whole and most
hilarious we say not entertained not
being able to get a movie made he
couldn't get the rocky whatever it was
made and and he [ __ ] was like sitting
at the bar and he's like well it's over
I had my run it's over I mean but dude
but still they still indie movie doesn't
matter you still like I did I had my run
it's a form of death and then his friend
came over how you doing I'm not doing
what not good does he want to make this
yeah and then this this this producer
said I read that script and made my wife
cry so anything like that I'm gonna yeah
I'm gonna I'm doing the movie but like
you know you always think that it's the
last time you're I've never met an actor
or any or a director didn't didn't feel
like this was their last gig that it
doesn't have done yes yeah you know
everybody ever I think being insecure
and insecure is is probably crucial
I don't know sure do you know anyone
who's not I don't know it you know any
or names not know I don't name the one
we should talk about this only because
you and I are around successful people
and there a lot of people who are
younger listening to this play when I
was on
when I was your age when I when I was
when I was in my 20s I thought people
who were up there were secure look I
thought that they had it all and they
did Arata have a theme but there's no
such thing know right like part of what
drives you is the fact that you always
feel like you're less than that's
certainly for me I mean I don't know
where I'd be if I didn't hate myself a
little bit so it's okay if you don't
like yourself what matters is just take
the actions and keep reaching you're
never gonna be self perfected but at
least you'll get close guys got guys in
shape guys got a [ __ ] he's got some
forearms gigantic yeah yeah he's veiny
dude he's feigning and I gotta get a
little more veining dude you're probably
the only guy in that room not on trt
think about it well Pacino's not no
Pacino's no but that's it everyone else
juice to the gills probably and I
celebrate it yeah probably right now I'd
love to talk about Tod yeah well
whatever he's doing it works yeah dude
you're Rambo you got to be on it you
can't let yourself go I mean he's
nothing more but he just stays in shape
look at that everyone who kind of
workout he's doing uh I was pretty
jacked to those for his age you never
stopped he's never stopped working out
he looks great
well oh Marla's gotta like his belly is
so flat like I said he's walks in he's
got a blazer on but you can see he's
just keeps it though there's a picture
aiming like a [ __ ] soon gun he's
pretty [ __ ] but how old is he Arnold
yeah what's odd what slide 70 wattle or
73 with a life Arnold come on an
immigrant the two-time governor of
California 72 years old
it's like Trump almost right yeah dude
how about he [ __ ] his warlock of a
cleaner and got her pregnant and it's
like yeah cool man I'm not gonna had a
kid I'm not gonna comment on I think she
was probably pretty sexy he's got his
son first sunny day is a happy kid
son son got his genetics yeah Alan have
you seen her Brian what when she was
younger when they [ __ ] dude when she was
young probably far less well now she's
an old laddie
when she was cleaning the house that's
not true
jover lady now she's no lady now and she
was younger uh that's her little younger
shut your [ __ ] mouth to me what I'm
saying is how cool is that that he did
that and just oh we did a baller move
he's such a [ __ ] maniac and me he's
such a guy's guy
he bright just got a shower but you know
she was there fluffing the pillows and
he's all all right it's go time
yeah right yeah well there there there
that's better than when she's younger
look go there when she's you know yeah
right there all right
you know the thing is you you can't you
ask you don't become the governor in the
seventh I'm it's not having appetite and
you don't become the Terminator by not
wanting to [ __ ] anything that moves okay
you got an appetite that picture is
amazing right there this guy is this guy
he's just got golf here's what's what a
handsome son of a [ __ ] here's what's
crazy about horse neighing his other
kids good-looking kid they don't have
his genetics muscular the max and kid
does he looks just like he's the own
that got his actual physical his man
yeah good-looking kid yeah and he's kind
of into bodybuilding yeah yes other kids
are into like acting and their feelings
and [ __ ] just kids Jack listen he's he's
God look at kid though the kids don't
look like that
hey he's Mexican dude do you know the
type of [ __ ] that what that kid's gonna
do with his work ethic and those genetic
did you take over the [ __ ] world
god bless me no Kevin handsome beautiful
boys listen man all because she was
fluffy god bless his mother god bless
his mother his mother was like you know
look he's an attractive dude who knows
what the situation was that whole
thing's crazy tiptoe around no we don't
situation feel uncommon aid I feel
uncomfortable because like you just
can't do that right but what a beautiful
result what a beautiful result what a
beautiful mistake but you can't
beautiful can have sex with the maid why
not it's in your house man why not well
Swiss finger why not
they're just some rules who knows what
they who maybe they're separated I
forgive all parties I forgive all
parties it's all good it's all good but
he's you know he died he owned it you
know you got the family together as I
care you know isn't morale de who's here
every Wednesday she's pregnant
they're like took clean that cetera yeah
is that true yeah you owned it just Oh
told him he did mm-hmm
but I don't think Maria Shriver knew
until it all came out did she
nope he told the family that's why
they're closed now they're all like
still they still like hanging out he did
what he wanted when he had sex with
everybody because they all wanted to
what kill you on that one when she's
walking on the beach which says
housekeeper claims he's a guy who walks
in more of a wife than Schwarzenegger oh
then Maria later I mean you know what
you know what here's the thing he
fathered that child well he loves that
boy we don't know that well it looks
like they hang out it looks like they
don't want to think they're gonna go
follow they they look he loves his son
dude they are like yeah that kid is a
spitting image as long as he's younger
boy loves this a father loves his kids
I'm good if you have if you want to have
14 kids love them all and treat them
well okay as long as you do that if you
don't I got no time for you bottom line
sir interesting yes sometimes just gotta
that kid's jacked it looks just like his
pop very has the same hair too we're out
of dude Lisa's genetics get you know
those monster genetics or someone yeah
men they live on than the young boy God
he looks like dad a full day especially
when Turner was young
you ever seen Alma at 16 let's not get
crazy now you've seen all that signagi
16 but I have when he was younger you
know no 16 years old there's a picture
of him in it's mind-blowing
he's yeah dude
yeah he was look at that there is 16
year old Jack that's good that's some
good genetics big Austrians a big
Austrian man grew up on milk that make
them kid got it man
I mean I'm gonna come to the United
States as an Austrian and and become the
biggest bodybuilding world the biggest
movie star in the world and the governor
twice over you know with you in a better
story what the maze I'm gonna come to
America get pregnant by the governor and
the biggest movie star of all time
third I have to say I got you think
about it bro that's a it's a coup it's
what we call a coup and it worked out
that is pretty amazing pretty amazing
why wouldn't you you got a little Arnold
in you never stop dreaming what you got
a little Arnold in you it's tough for
guys like let's say let's say my gut
let's say my goal is to get Kim
Kardashian pregnant it's gonna be a
tough run for your boy how do I get in
there I can't clean a house no no no
scan I army ISM you could be the pool
boy no no higher my big s is the pool
boy how can I get in the house to be
around my my feelings and how am I gonna
get in a room here's what I saw the
shower and I dicker down here's what I
think if you were there as the personal
trainer dude if you know and tell how
we're gonna do it you're right now this
is a great idea you go you come in there
with your cauliflower ears your big old
long hair now yeah and you got you got
you got an SS come at me John Stamos I'm
at me John Stamos and by the way you're
just there to spot you do their spot
let's do some squats yeah I'm gonna make
sure you're hit bill debris nerds bring
your hips in a little bit is brilliant
bring us in a little bit there you go
and now you're just talking this way
that's it there you go now breathe
breathe breathe I got you I got you
don't worry I know it's a lot of weight
I got you I got you I got you there you
go all the way down can you go a little
further
there you go I'm gonna help yep okay
they say no I'm dumping her in the pool
house don't be froze
don't say dumping it's Kim Kardashian
have a little respect or Kylie either or
it bliss it I'll make hot
I with them than the maid I may call you
break you at the end of the day you're
gonna break you're gonna break them all
down
you're gonna break Chloe seems like a
tough case to crack but I'm not a tough
case you see there seems like a tough
case she might be the first to go at the
end of the day all the Kardashians have
a little shop in them but yeah and they
all have your kid I'm not black tough
they only like black boys you're almost
black dude you're Samoan black Mexican
youyou be a lot of things yeah I get a
hybrid gotchas a baddie like black women
love you there they're all like here so
it doesn't because you're you're you're
at your ethnically ambiguous dude that
racially ambiguous dude that is the move
though I go in as was that trainer
little Kylie she's something else that
doctor no that one's cam cam yeah yeah
that doctor can mine mine that
presenting I thought that Brazilian butt
thing that they do is incredible they
take the fat and just displace it now
you know the new thing they do they take
fat people can go donate their fat like
a sperm bank and they take that fact I
don't think so it's hard you're a lot
every job they do it's a new thing and
it's a powder form they turn into a
powder form how I know all this I have
no idea yeah I was watching it last
night
Wow crazy she gots a bud dumper you got
that yeah it's strange to have all that
fat but good good for you I'm not mad at
it
man well you got the right doctors you
can do some [ __ ] huh you do anything
really die skin now too right cuz guys
can get lipo guys can get abs guy can
get yeah but you can see it on dude
that's weird
yeah for girls I celebrate dudes it's a
little strange
yeah double standard in it well John
Travolta if you look at John Travolta's
face he's got lots of work done now my
god you know it's like oh you don't know
John's wrote them whatever you know yeah
he said some work well documented
I have the guy for the dad from Parent
Trap there look at that Dennis Quaid
Dennis Quaid face looks like in my
[ __ ] doll Dennis Quaid oh no he was
on Jimmy Kimmel I'm like well you gotta
chill out with the feeling no
dude Dennis Quaid well he's gay he's
dating a 22 year old or some [ __ ]
yeah he's 40 years older and I see slide
before bottom left come on Dennis you
don't need to do this top get to go up
one can't see he looks different though
yeah I thumb and get one without the
makeup on like that that looks different
than sometimes you've got to do it you
know yeah just you still have just get
old dude yeah I'm old school this tough
I don't get it I could ask you though
yeah yeah he's like Frank rules like
this booze he ya booze they eat you huh
yeah I've gotten really into dip in
lately Brian muscular guy though he had
a great body look at oh yeah he's bodied
up always was bodied up that was just
him stays in shape still still kind of
jacked booze booze aged a little bit
though who's yappin burn the paint on
the whiskey man it looks like you [ __ ]
there it looks kind of like he looks
like I'm what's that gorillas older
brother yeah like one of those one of
those tunnel rat dogs
I've just got to like Frank Rios older
brother I'm going to the doctor yes he
does yes he looks like Frank Grillo
Zolder breath that's exactly what he
looks like that's your brother that
technically wait says me as Frank's
older brother that's me as Frank's older
brother looks like you and Frank had a
baby yeah and as Quaid says he wants to
cocaine on a daily basis yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude
live live biggest movie star in the
world for a long time and that great was
he the big [ __ ] he's phenomenal he
was like he's a great actor I love you
still I always loved him yeah he was
wonderful uh how old is his girl
whatever she is she's in delicious
she's delicious this is my thing ask any
guy watch you what is your type hot hot
it's long it's legal hot yeah 26 26 and
he's how old 65 I don't get I'm fine
with it
one guy got a young chick what do you
want she likes him now I know you want
something you have to it's a little
dicey it's ty see because you're not
everyone marries for love you forget
about yeah but sometimes a woman has
attracted to an older man sometimes made
for a financial security
how same-sex big house big dick Oh
sometimes love's last night equation
what it's more of an agreement you know
more of an agreement
is there anybody older as a woman that
you find oh god don't be this you stop
doing that yeah Elizabeth Hurley hottest
[ __ ] yeah yeah she's good doing kids
with her but yeah
yeah she's good yeah Lisbeth Hurley's a
smoke show yes well there's a few it's
weird when a young guy dates an older
girl though a little bit double standard
yeah cher Madonna they did their they
date young men so Elizabeth Hurley is
just just delicious still kills it Oh
God she is fantastic yeah Robin writes
those same real and real cat in the sack
guitar there oh look at her there though
God and she's British she's delicious
one of my all-time favorites Wow has to
be yeah may or may not have a friend who
was hung out with her for a little bit
for a name Bill Clinton no look at her
there look at no go down to the bubble
go down to the bikini shot there that's
just she those are just stupendous does
she have children oh yeah oh she does oh
yeah I think she has a son I'll tell you
what that who's the other yeah it's
always weird when it's a young dude and
an older chick it's always awkward yeah
it never works out name one that's
worked out now ray Fiennes
was married to a macho who the Prime
Minister of the President of France
Markham his wife is I think 20 years
older than him do you know that but how
did they meet how old were that when
they
they're very young so Brigitte Marco and
she's probably almost 70 now I think and
he's my age it's such a double standard
though in there it's a double standard
it's so like she's c6 she's 66 my con is
it's let me look at that difference
that's the president that's her husband
mm-hmm he's 41 yeah he's a 1 he's how
old 4166 and 41 that's not - Wow no
what'd you say 20 yeah but after after
when you're when you if you're after 40
hey it's still 25 I know but it's
different it's different when it's a
young girl 25 no I'm saying that's a man
who's 41 and she his wife is 66 I know
but they're both Oh
so who 41 is only a couple years older
than you
yeah but they're both older the point is
when it's a man named Matt back but
here's the man at 65 and a girl at 25 is
my ears different than a 45 year old a
65 year old yeah I mentally spiritually
everything is crap they've experienced
life they're older that's cuz they're
more knowledgeable it's just a different
Wow Wow I don't be nice um that's just a
different you know I'm saying
have you ever one day because you're a
doctor - that's what have you talked to
20 year old that's the problem and then
you're gonna hang out with him for life
no but it happens it how successfully
though huh not successfully sometimes my
good friend Sly Stallone his wife is 19
he was 42 still married sometimes it
works out depending sometimes it works
he was 42 she was 19
yeah gorgeous oh here's what to your
example Oh Jay met Nicole when she was
17 well hasn't that worked out
for a while dead kids yeah yeah just wow
oh yeah that's right got that kid from
Avengers it says right yeah I know from
how old is she
Wow that's gonna Oh 23 years that's an
age gap Heusen kick-ass together was
heyguys that's right that's an age gap
that's a big age yep but they just must
vibe on a different frequency
he might be an older soul exactly exact
cause you're a younger soul your oldest
dirt but your turn you have more of a
younger soul yes we don't know you're
not like hip with anything but you like
yeah you're like young dear energy
energy filly yeah well they both yeah
that's the bit that one's interesting
for Collinson 30 minutes yeah share Tom
please
well yeah there's been some young ones
it's always weird yeah god bless man
like you're such a well-read dude you
couldn't like date a 19 year old back
when to you very tough if there's time
at Instagram like ya [ __ ] doing
stories in Torquay like yes look at me
my boob and like twerk in on your books
and [ __ ] you're not my books huh baby
it's working I'm have I told you get off
the books
yeah wait can we talk about something
yeah well in this town there's also that
professional hot girl element that's
never been something I can deal with
ever Oh what do you mean I've never been
able I never said the hot the hot you
know the hot professional girl did
they're just a hot girl yeah she's just
hot it's like in deep down you're like I
wanna have sex with her yeah but to hang
with her to hang with girls like that to
go through the process to go through the
hangout period to get it you mean Dan
that's exhaust you mean dinner yeah but
even more I always always feel a little
bit bad about myself I would always feel
like a bit of a chump cuz I was like
doing it I was starting out it was a lie
to start out with does that make sense
what do you mean you you were you're
gonna be in a relationship with her yeah
cuz I'm there I'm talking about I'm
and I'm and I'm I'm contorting myself to
be somebody I'm not I'm listening to her
and laughing and she's not really
there's no connection and at the end of
the day we're gonna eat and go [ __ ] okay
cool but I would always feel like a liar
I was doing it Brennan film an entire
where'd you go feel like you're a lot oh
I'm not gonna stand for it on the spot
yet no but I mean I'm saying
you mean wine and dine and then charming
just to [ __ ] a girl well yes there's
that but I'm saying sometimes when the
girl is just hot and a [ __ ]
that's a problem you feel like an idiot
you feel like you're kind of in the same
boat somehow like you're corrupting mmm
I don't know man
you know what I mean you go to parties
and it's all porn chicks oh look at my
dad's yeah like oh man what am I gonna
do here talk for a while and I'm we're
we're gonna go go off and hang and I'm
gonna [ __ ] pretend to listen and try
to have something in common just so I
can get in your pants exactly what we're
gonna done that many of them no I
haven't I I'm not saying I don't want to
in a moment but you know you got a I'm
not saying Miriam for god sakes
well you want to move him in I don't
there are guys that do that though huh
they're the guys that fall for that [ __ ]
she's a really sweet girl she's a hooker
she's a SAP dumbass
she's a savvy guy that falls in love
with how do you not see that we have a
friend like that don't we do don't we
yeah and now he's important oh no that's
different
he's he knows what's up the savage do
vodcast know he knows yeah it's TV blue
eyes in the party support Donna that's
awesome well Stevie went from criminal
to comic to porn star it's kind of set
he sent me his first did he send me his
debut I was very impressed got a dick on
that's a week and I I watched it alone
where's the body cam what you know that
where's a body cam yeah that's how I got
the kind of thing that it's just weird
of you although with the kind of police
wear a body cam only he's got he's got
on his chest with no shirt on oh no I
gave him a someone gave me a GoPro and I
gave it to him he goes who I'm gonna use
to film I stand up blah blah blah this
was years ago and then I get a video
look two weeks Ilias do
finally put that GoPro to use that he
gave me I'm like well what is it click
it sim beat cheese I remember I remember
you gave him that you know what you
didn't know what to do
oh he's using it now he's using his
covered and come but whatever yeah those
things are waterproof yeah it'll be fine
Stevie that's a dick only that dude got
a dick on him he just finds his way to
the top of everything he does it's
really interesting he's making they're
gonna send him all over the world
pornhub sends him all over the world to
[ __ ] it's beautiful all right there you
go that's what you want to do he's legit
he's finally legit you can pay taxes now
that's what you want to do man
but the nuts hate he goes now I get to
work out I got an excuse I can't wait
yeah all he does out he's perfect oh
yeah he'll have a perspective like he
always does on [ __ ] one time he said
something really interesting he goes he
said um if you're this is back in the
day he went to jail for six years so
this is back in the day when he was
making money and he goes if you count a
million dollars on a counter you if you
don't wear a mask you're getting sick
and I was like what he goes you gotta
wear a mask cuz when until his cow it
Steve Legos making movies and Chris do
they put the time where you come
question park god his girl is just
delicious
I mean her work man man yeah look at him
he's such a character he's the best with
his off-white sneakers yeah what a crazy
[ __ ] dude out of his mind I love it
we're gonna get him on the podcast right
quick the first one hub Award
diversifying my portfolio he's amazing
yeah it takes a special kind of dude to
data porn star man like [ __ ]
now he's date one you know like that's
your girl he does what what he wanted
he's a guy whose life is a circus he
just goes with the flow enjoys it
everybody likes him he's impossible
not to like everyone loves him and he's
[ __ ] really intelligent he's just
smart yours team played a guitar oh yeah
yeah Stan it's great does it all anyway
yeah we'll have money let's go some
current events Brandon what you're a
lucky man
why you got a thick head of hair yep
woke up like this
now my hair I'd be bald as a cucumber I
can promise you that if it wasn't for my
whatever hair ties my didn't care didn't
go didn't go but I'll tell you what I
use I use hymns oh man is finasteride
the only thing that really truly holds
on your hair clinically proven is
finasteride they talk about sexual
byproducts have problems I'm 52 I use
finasteride from hims every day not to
be too much of a you know but I can cut
a diamond with my piece yeah all right
so if you look at the actual results
it's it's very very slim some people
have problems with their issues but the
bottom line is you want to hold on your
hair the way I have there's one thing to
do you can get finasteride for hims
you'd fill out a little questionnaire
exactly yeah [ __ ] you here man pills
yeah no more awkward yep no more awkward
and person doctor visits they send it
straight to your door
well it's not gas station counter
supplements straight to your door man
and you guys can get five dollars you
can get for five dollars complete hair
kit for five dollars today while
supplies last and subject that doctor's
approval see website for full detail
safety information this could cost
hundreds if you went to a doctor
pharmacy somewhere else go to for hems
coms last fighter that's four hams fo
are hims calm slash by to her hair grow
hair get thicker hair it actually does
that I am living proof I'll tell you why
bro I'll tell you what I can't you know
I'm stressed out about what holidays and
your teeth are back to being crumpled up
a little back there kind of back to
being crumpled up we need to even your
teeth out still burn yours broke but not
really
good neither one know what's good we
both had some issues now we wish there
was something we could do I'm not going
to the dentist to do this whole thing no
it's candid candid makes it so much
easier okay you can get photo ready
right now photo ready your aligners from
Canada
forget braces okay it can help strain
your teeth faster than our traditional
wire braces it takes six months on
average an experienced orthodontics
orthodontist who's licensed in your
state creates a custom treatment plan
they show you a 3d preview so you can
actually see what your teeth are gonna
look like when your oh it's pretty close
months and you basically where am i
nobody can tell I did it for a long time
yeah yeah this hands aligners are
comfortable removal and completely
invisible I went with another company I
might go back in the house right guys
candid ships your aligners directly to
you so there's no hassle of going to an
orthodontist office and canid cause this
is huge 65% less than braces all right
well I spent a fortune on another
company and with each aligner purchases
Kennedy donate $25 to smile train one of
my favorite charities they fix cleft
palates and it brings 100% free cleft
lip and palate treatment to children
around the globe dude I'm gonna have a
photo ready smile by this Christmas you
can to go to candied co.com slash fight
or use code fighter get $75 off that's
candied code calm slash fighter toad
fight over $75 off yeah okay so a
college student from Minnesota every
Saturday for the past year or so has
been driving from his college to the
closest Krispy Kreme and it just so
happens to be in Iowa so he drives over
200 miles every Saturday to go pick up a
hundred boxes of donuts and he will sell
them for between 17 to 20 dollars
sometimes people want them so badly that
they'll pay $100 per box because the
closest one to them is he's over 200
miles per hour Krispy Kreme found out
about it and told them that they had
that he had to stop doing it or else
they would then sue him for reselling
well [ __ ] that's not but the market
value that you'd like then you do it
Krispy Kreme exactly
I think they're trying to now open up
another storefront closer to Minnesota
but the closest one was in Iowa so this
guy every Saturday has been making a
four-hour drive to Iowa and a four-hour
drive back to load up his cars with I
like I love his entrepreneurial spirit
me too so you know Krispy Kreme I keep
doing it and just let him sue ya Krispy
Kreme put we aggressively what happens
we appreciate Jase's past when Krispy
Kreme is entrepreneurial spirit as he
pursues his education what about you hey
yeah man take it easy take it easy right
he's buying your [ __ ] Donuts yeah
he's cleaning you out what's the problem
you're guaranteed to be creamer I'm so
hungry could scream I'm nice when
they're warm I'm not crazy about too
sweet for me one too sweet boxcar
sidecar sidecar yeah oh oh expensive
donut expensive Donuts but it's pretty
good yeah that that maple glaze or
whatever it is sweet
I think voodoo is really good in between
voodoo number one by far the chocolate
glaze no that's the crazy what else you
got
you did the Obama one first or something
so you guys were referring to this just
a little bit ago Obama had a talk and he
basically said that his stance on cancer
culture is that it's not activism and he
doesn't think it helps anything he's
right doing collagen we complain not as
usual very alcohol but I didn't get a
sense sometimes now among certain young
people and this is accelerated by social
media there is this sense sometimes of
the way of me making change is to be as
judgmental as possible about other
people and that's enough like if I tweet
or hash tag about how you didn't do
something right or use the word wrong
verb or then I can sit back and feel
pretty good about myself because man you
see how awoke I was I called you out
that's not that's not activism no that's
not bringing about change me so he's
slowly spinning what's crazy what's or
whatever you know whatever side you lie
on with Trump and it's so crazy listen
Trump speaking on him yeah
it's just I mean he's an eloquent
speaker and I think that that's and
that's appointed I had my issues with
him in terms of policy but I liked what
he had to say there I think it's
important a very sensible guy smart guy
but yeah what is good so have you guys
seen the models who flashed their tits
during the World Series five get on Game
five all three of them flashed my nose
two of them - my understanding was
caught on camera I think the third one
might have been there - they're smoking
hot but they're legitimately models
they're actual models they were maybe
they were planning this for about a year
that they wanted to go to the World
Series game and flash their boobs one to
like help promote them in their careers
and - they said that it was to bring
awareness to breast cancer thanks girls
you're really because we none of us know
about breast cancer until you guys
showed us your tits none of us know good
but do dead now now we can look forward
to a cure yeah since the tens showed us
that perfect is Gerrit Cole over there
trying to distract if he can't notice it
um I don't know if he noticed it but it
didn't [ __ ] up his pitch so he was
perfectly fine but the two girls who
were caught flashing their tits are now
banned forever from any MLB sporting
event that's out there can I see this
can I see them this one had his first
one in the second one let's just try
both real quick just give her a minute
so gutsy that's refresh so lame it's so
hilarious
right there and the yellow shirts
now that one goes
he's not even noticing that what he
stops that was kind of no don't watch
this one the three of them did this it
seems like there was only two
[Applause]
all right girls he kind of dumped it
here we're about to do this we're going
crazy we're gonna be [ __ ] nuts
I mean flashes singing they're so lame
girls like this okay that's kind of lame
yeah she's pretty hot though
they're all hot as [ __ ] I mean this one
here is riddles like yo we just flash
the whole [ __ ] world says and it took
them a year to plan out well that's a
long letter listen guys that's a real
ocean Ocean's eleven that's a real
Ocean's eleven move there girls
you guys are real heroes
all right well listen thanks for the
tits thanks for your tits you post
pictures of your tits of course
immediately and let me see what's going
on well work they're getting [ __ ]
marketing now that's all they want it
awesome
yeah okay buqun YouTube took a lot take
a lot of courage mascara took a lot of
courage breast cancer okay yeah I'm sure
the pain thank God thank God and we can
now look forward to a cure what else get
to and a lot of people have been tagging
us in this episode - didn't Kutcher just
got his brown belt a big deal from Hagen
[ __ ] oh there's no it's just as big of a
picture yep oh there he goes
nine years interesting video though huh
good train good training how long's I
get my Brahma brother I don't know dude
you keep training with him man calls
calls calls calls calls calls calls what
belt are you on now oh I'm a pencil blue
belt
yeah I don't consider that anymore I
gotta get it I gotta start all over yet
how long it take to get a blue the
average the average person yeah that's
how much train praise three to four
years damn I didn't know I think demi
lovato is a blue belt to me village it
plays really ok blue blue blue purple
brown black right
alrighty yeah even if you're not a
Silurian to you alone Brandon Brandon
what man I got my black bought yesterday
necessarily you got what else you
alright this is from last week but John
I mean you didn't get your black belt
for ever yeah train every day
professionally for hours yeah yeah
wait what's that have to do your point
to go like you're you're a tenor are
here on school and you get a black belt
you earned it
why would I got my black belt from a
mall Easton yeah if I was stayed there I
probably got my black belt they asked me
to come back a while ago - you got a you
got a real quickly though how I don't
even have you have you been trained to
not get it quickly how long have you
been training eight years oh okay
everyday everyday easy on there yeah
yeah I don't know is that long yeah
that's a long time yeah eight years yeah
every day - again your celebrity blue
bells purple belts brown belt it's just
a different path different path yeah if
you're competitive with it yeah it's
gonna I mean wouldn't they know to like
especially if let's just say Demi
Lovato's belt isn't legitimately a blue
belt wouldn't she roll with other blue
belts just regular blue it's not what
they wouldn't put her in yet what
happens in those school is that if
you're rolling with Demi Lovato also
it's not you know your Demi Lovato yeah
yeah
but also who she had a blue belt in
there I don't know it's the same place
longer Wiz Khalifa and Snoopy Glaser
yeah I see Brandon's face yeah she's not
you know she's not like that is a
celebrity Jenner you know like Madonna
hair you know yeah I noticed that like
certain schools like when you're a blue
belt if you're a purple belt on their
hands Oh in comparison to other schools
like you it was such it was such a
difference it was like [ __ ] light
years different light years who knows
how hard didn't you know
lavage she might be training all the
time we don't know how much she's
training to I don't know she might be
legit why don't ya when I go on TRT I'm
training every [ __ ] day good luck
guys are you really gonna do it
no I'm shooting a TV show I have a
podcast to children and I just stand up
so it's very difficult to find time
literally just like practice on my only
say no et RTOG trt have you not I do
though I don't know I was talking to
Brendan about I don't feel like I need
it my dick can still cut a diamond and I
have a lot of energy I just don't want
to [ __ ] with that but you want to get
bigger right
really I say that but look we're here
what am I gonna do okay look so what I
learn get more veiny I that do did for
me to do that would be a little bit
look just I'm Who I am skinny guy you're
not skinny though no I could put on five
more pounds maybe look more muscular
awesome alright
for how long I have I have to tell you
that for me when I when I and I maybe
I'm wrong when I see older dudes who do
TRT and I see anybody does TRT even like
they start in their forties I think it
ages you I I noticed how to keep the
same energy when you go to stones house
now [ __ ] all this [ __ ] well I think
it's the same energy you have right now
he's pretty to face so when you go over
there you're right you guys look grave
who said that you know they do look
great and strong looks great yeah but
that's what I'm working out probably
eats like a [ __ ] Spartan and you know
it's a lifetime of close to the bone you
know but TRT those guys are on John same
energy keep the same energy talking all
this [ __ ] but over there sucking the
boys off tell you the toughest guy in
that room was who is the toughest guy in
that room by far
who'd be who beats up everybody in that
room money's brown bill burr no money's
not bill burr [ __ ] mercenaire bill burr
it's a comic stuff okay you go
shut up good comic shut up man he good
bill burr Al Pacino hey before you keep
it [ __ ] none of your tough but keep
going
hola chica Dober Al Pacino Frank Grillo
there uh Dolph
we've got Dolph Lundgren I don't know
dolf's background keep going so Tony up
his every bit of six five don't care
about size four tell he's every better
his Swedish knees he care if he's every
bit as probably weighs if you look at
his hands his head probably weighs at
least 235
- he's not six - I was standing next to
him he sees that's hilarious that one it
says he's only 62
Oh 62 yeah but when he was younger and
he's still in great shape I mean he's a
[ __ ] house and he was also European
kickboxing champion you know look at him
when he was younger
he's always I'll scroll up chin there it
is he showed some interest drumming he
took up karate at age 10 began lifting
weights um oh he's on the karate team
you want to turn him in when he was only
a green belt he won the European
Championships and a heavyweight term in
Australia graduated with a chemical
engineering in karate or was it
kickboxing is a big diff karate he'll
shake in karate your skin is they
actually do kick and punch they actually
spar there could been a couple guys in
UFC early time who are killing karate
guys so big you want to tournament big
run guy very big strong athletic guy
very strong like like like I died with
you easy easy that's a big guy hmm you
know and an athletic but I'm four five
years in karate look at him what he's
younger for a second take a look at mine
is younger yeah it's right here
or younger yeah I mean he's a big 200
and [ __ ] 35 pack that big guy you know
that that's a lot of then and athletic
looking at their younger coming you know
from the rest of us as regular guys
that's a big dude it just did a lot of
body then move why you
oh what's the point he's just a big dude
Sandi's the self he's probably the most
athletic guy in the room
definitely aesthetic Chris Jones you're
saying if like a fight broke out with
all the yeah I think he's gonna he's got
a head this pig I mean he's his life
he's angry he's just a different weight
class well hope he hasn't fight man you
never know dude you never you never know
I want to see him she loves 52 7
year-olds anybody taking a
moving around is definitely taking yeah
punching oh there we go
[ __ ] yeah this right here in the park
right get get that sidekick that dude oh
they're just look YouTube Dolph shows
some karate moves did you see it you
missed it yeah big ass trophy that's
best thing about like karate those
giving us a giant try so jealous
football we have this giant trophies oh
[ __ ] yeah dude
come get some Al Pacino I definitely
don't feel like leaving right now no no
I decide to Britain have you do that cuz
I knew you're lying right it's what I
was told I don't want no no you guys all
get around this guy's a kickbike
chairman you I'm sure you brought up
your karate day no I did and Frank threw
in his boxing no I didn't know I didn't
and there was a daze I still bought in
this guy and I do and I stole and I do
Jiu Jitsu I'm depressed I don't know if
all the energies left my body oh man
wait what else you guys got just get me
out of here let's just do it but that's
the one [ __ ] on everything dude no I
bring back down to reality
what kickboxing champion you have any
idea what that means
if any clue what that holds I was told
by European kickboxing chairman yep I
don't know it was you somewhere I'm good
you have to be a kickboxing to be a
European champion - big deal yeah well
so no one believes it I was [ __ ] told
that but you know fighting that's what
bothers me you know fighting so when
someone goes he's oh you wanted to be
sure I just wanted I go really
what my favorite is Brendan like this
wait what do you say what is he oh here
he thinks funny I can look it up right
now actually Brian had this friend that
lied all the time
all the [ __ ] time I thought this guy
I thought this guy like what what year
was that you like I was like in 94 like
okay 94 and where was it at I mean I can
google it just where was it at
I'll just tell me I look up the name and
there was zero and I was like he's like
oh I was actually sound was actually on
sanction remembers like Mexico they
didn't have cameras oh the worst is the
best light and this mate brought me so
much happiness Brian kept going oh he's
legit he's legit okay I'm not gonna I
don't want out this guy he goes oh I
wrestled at this school my head coach
wrestled there how old are you oh you
guys the same age she would wrestle yes
oh yeah I know him I go to my head coach
you go hey do sketches uh-huh never
heard of them yeah well no he saves on
the team though is no I would know the
team we weren't very close bunch so I go
down I go hey man I talk to my coach he
he doesn't remember he goes oh dude I
wasn't on the team yeah they would let
me go in to the practices as a student
and I would help the guys out now well
that's against the theta wave rules that
doesn't sure you can't just go in train
with the team go try walking on the UCLA
football practice I think what I love
about but this is to me this is common
say I'm a degree I mean I agree you but
that's what bothers what if somebody
tells me they do something what I do is
I go I believe you it's writing well in
general like don't lie don't like if you
say Brian what did you do I go I won the
[ __ ] I was in Taekwondo and I and I
fought I competed in tournaments and
then what's the next thing I say go
didn't punch in the face you kick in the
head
some guys were getting knocked out I was
alright but I also know that everybody
who did Tech when it wasn't really an
athlete the over the athletes were doing
other sports so you don't care about any
of that do you know what I'm saying
when people have no idea good I'm saying
what people go I'm not gonna lie and say
to you I was a but you know amateur box
or something I would never do that but
some people do when that's to me it's
always surprising it's for what really
annoys when they do it with people in
the business yeah okay who's your coach
Yeah right
Orion right there's gonna be some that's
what fozzy degrees of separation' racket
we can look
find out also also don't lie about it
don't make up these big lies Oh guys lie
oh the old the farther away you get from
older people buy it the farther you go
away you get from your glory days the
bigger your glory days become sometimes
and then the internet [ __ ] those old
guys huh the internet [ __ ] them because
there's record of - from the 1900 well I
got a lot out of here's what I say here
if you ask me about me I'll go like this
I go um I was when I the first time my
dance teacher saw me in a leotard she
said where did you dance now this is
true I say I never danced she goes you
have legs like that and never danced
because I was I'm built like a frog and
I look like I've been doing yeah no
question like did I could be from and
there's no question that I could jump
and do crazy baby from I did four
pirouettes and all that and then I do
this though this is what I add in I go
the thing is I always thought I was
built for endurance but I'm I'm mostly
fast twitch muscle I love saying that
because my genome said it and then I go
I've always been an athlete then I say
that is what I say the girls I go I've
always been an athlete that's the kind
of shallow thing but I'm general but I I
say cuz it makes me feel good I'm like
but don't you feel weird co-signing
dolph lundgren as a world champion
kickboxer here I was just told he was
European champion when he was there but
why don't you guys do this really what
year well you know what I think about I
wasn't there all these different
divisions right yeah it's crazy champion
yeah what year we're at oh no there's no
record of it anywhere huh
what's Dolph Lundgren a real boxer let
me see I typed in kickboxing record
Hassan and martial artist this right
mm-hmm
okay yeah still say beat up everybody in
the room because he's still awesome guy
very good guy says I'm sure you knows
karate
yeah oh well Bobby I'm sure even if you
asked him he like not was no world
champion let's see that see that though
it looks like he's about to fight no
please no yeah yeah that's where he
fights actually he fights uh he fights
all like knocked off oh yeah I forgot
about this hold on hold on
you flights are 30 2011 you know what
every box is still what's it nice is in
there taking shots but at least he's
fighting and the all I'm saying is as a
guy this big is probably gonna give
anybody in that room and that's not
saying much I'm sange without potatoes I
stick to my point is that Dolph Lundgren
beats everybody never him up and at
least he was training right
so all anxiety went down this way
traveled no one's arguing with you okay
Al Pacino's 19 I'm a Dolph and okay I'm
a dolphin too I just know you was a
world Pacino in Scarface if you put him
in it it comes back he kills everybody
in that room probably dude even if
especially if he's got cocaine he's got
guns yeah dawg I mean Dolph's by far the
biggest freak athletically in that room
that's what I'm saying you know the last
thing I would think about in that room
what I do
who's our flat it the last thing you'd
think about is the first thing I think
about yeah it's very strange
yeah the last thing you think about is
always the first thing I would not give
a [ __ ] yeah I'd probably shot down if
they start talking to me about their
fighting careers or uh now they wouldn't
like martial arts and [ __ ] hey you know
what it was it wasn't that they're all
funny
it's obviously silly good stuff nobody's
everybody tellurian and you brought it
to this level yeah guys he's a friend of
mine um those guys that you know that
that end up being somewhat Liars
sometimes odd are they friends ears that
you known for a while we're just
randomly not my friend some of the dudes
you know from you know my accent Ryan's
work with them on and off times but you
don't know him anymore
not really he's a nice guy
yeah compulsive liar that sucks the lies
were fantastic though very safe at Chet
Congo on the beach
might rain check on hey check your
cyclist guy alright Beno okay
I'm a beat hey Chuck said you never
fight you on the live shows you will
remember yeah the greatest when you when
you have specific lies when you get
super specific it's the best that's the
best for them in a funhouse what we're
in a funhouse we're doing cocaine and I
knocked him out the other way just want
to say flat check coming on a beach I
just happen me train with check on that
black house two weeks later hey do you
know this guy never heard of them you
found a beach that never happened yeah
yeah don't say that
other way guys I got a train let's go
let's do some current events all right
just one more you've already heard this
everyone in the news
yeah the promise is well what - brother
was the one yeah so that's the problem
but he wasn't at war Marie
his brother hired this guy hired this
guy New York Medical Examiner so he was
more Pro like conspiracy theory it's
more consistent with a homicidal
strangling than it is a suicidal you
know hanging that's what he was saying
whatever that means and then so that
wasn't really the news cuz thats
everywhere right now but then this guy
who was a dog expert was on fox dog
expert yeah cuz you know that one dog
that was important in the killing that
Isis leader guy yeah it was Malinois or
something yeah I think this guy says
hold up I thought this dog if Bert was
weighing in on the EPS tone no he just
throws it in the very light and he can't
wait so thank you and thank nero for
your service i appreciate it
absolutely if i could could I throw a
PSA out real quick real quick just the
the remarkable nature of these dogs and
them being highlighted in the news
creates a huge demand by people that
frankly shouldn't have them if if you
see the the coverage and you decide I
want one of these dogs either by a
finished trained you know fully trained
and finished dog from a professional or
just just don't get one at all that and
Epstein didn't kill himself
hey guys that was great you didn't know
what to do it is all okay Wow combs know
that that's great that guys in the
military said that he's an expert dog
trainer oh he's an expert that's so
funny awesome way to go viral mode
that's how Larry that's fun he's right
about those dogs don't care very true
yes those those dogs like that every
trainer I know our boy Nick West is that
his name he said he goes don't get one
of those dogs because you don't get a
high drive dog you had there the problem
is that they're [ __ ] is like having a
race car yeah they will bite more so
than a race car they will bite
somebody's leg in a spaceship yeah you
know like somebody that comes in the
wrong way
yeah I'd be free you say the wrong word
if you have to have that dog with you
24/7 and you have to trust your boy yeah
it's a [ __ ] it's a it's a [ __ ]
it's chaos this cast
yes those dogs are not there's serious
animals they're called it's what they
call sharp dogs they're smart as [ __ ]
are you wise to put a leash on a
crocodile yeah they'll bite the [ __ ] I
had a crocodile coverage ever my buddy
had one he was SWAT sergeant and a kid
comes in with his friend and the dog
goes oh it was a shepherd and he goes
you afraid of dogs and the kid goes yeah
he's looking at this wolf he goes he
senses that don't act weird that what he
do there though what the [ __ ] is
supposed to do do that dog is a [ __ ]
wolf and it's looking at me
there there it's a liability yeah I love
him but it's a liability yeah you gotta
know how to you gotten out of hand
you'd be a you gotta be a veteran get a
fully finished dog and know that you
have to keep that [ __ ] kenneled
if you're away cuz if somebody comes in
your house they're getting bit they are
amazing dogs though yeah they're cool
they're incredible but they're not for
they're for professionals great III
don't want to see a bunch of civilians
breed these dogs now and have those dogs
and then it's just ridiculous they're
too smart to be neglect at all that's it
for realz Brian be responsible Dallas
I'm in brown yes Nick November 14 15 16
next weekend goes like City next I got a
brother
next Thursday Friday Saturday Dallas the
week after Matt's art club
wise guys wise guys is that Thanksgiving
now that's that's November 21st through
the 23rd and yeah right before
Thanksgiving and then who my kid was
coming then whatever we'll figure it out
and then Kansas City December 6 through
the 7th and the big boi bort bort a
gotcha or got Atlantic City once your
only Saturday December 14th and then
this just announced literally my
favorite Club favorite time san diego-la
jolla california comedy were comstor you
are tommy store la jolla i do that next
time that is December 19th through 21st
get your takes now to fat K calm I'm
coming down open for you
alright dude that man I'm gonna come
down one night they'll be fun yeah for
real
yeah easy drive I love it down there I
love it I've sanded my favorites well
hang I'd love to I love it you forget
out scary stories 55 minutes do it quick
ah you know what you should do slightly
it's lies I was gonna say you know you
should do is get out his lies about your
party was fun made me out of Pacino's
I'm friends with all those guys now you
are well hopefully I'll be a Dolph
straining maybe I'll show you some
videos of being world champion you know
man I have to take this [ __ ] either
I'm out of here is that it dude
good to see ya just a fine kid we're out